this is really hard it is but this is
hard for everybody at CBS News I haven't
talked about this before because when
you think about it I think the most
powerful media executive in America has
now resigned in the wake of this
Nietzsche movement and he's my boss
or he was my boss and so that makes it
really hard to comment on it les has
always treated me fairly and with
respect still it's been for me it's been
another sleepless night thinking about
this the pain that women feel the
courage that it takes for women to come
forward and talk about this and I really
didn't know what I was gonna say this
morning I need know I needed to say
something so Gail and I have have talked
and texted and and I said you know Gail
I'm kind of looking back to November
when we dealt with accusations against
our former co-host and Gail sort of said
yeah but you know I didn't think we'd
still be the story in September and 10
months later we're still talking about
this but here's what I said back then
and I think it still holds and I want to
say it again there is no excuse for this
alleged behavior it is systemic and it
is pervasive in our culture and this I
know is true to the core of my being
women cannot achieve equality in the
workplace or society until there is a
reckoning and the taking of
responsibility so I'm really proud to
work here at CBS News this has hurt
morale but there are some really really
good people that come to work every
single day as a journalist I'm confident
that the truth is going to come out
because this is being investigated there
are two prominent investigations going
on by some really good lawyers and this
has to end and the story will continue
and we'll continue to report on it just
like we would anything else and I'm
really proud to hear you say that
that and and I was I was talking to
somebody this week and I'm very close to
had something like this happen to them
30 years ago it still stays with her not
only the feeling in the moment but the
powerlessness afterwards and so I just
couldn't agree more with what you said
thanks Lori
and as you said Eureka you'll continue
to report on these developments as you
always have as we as a news organization
have thank you very much for that
Thanks